m
on commence à partir du 23 novembre
ici était actions fleury avec la
compagnie xy c'est une compagnie tient
qu'à 24 circassiens du plateau et médias
ou de la fille donne franchement il ce
pas tout il court partout non c'est
vraiment un spectacle extraordinaire ça
qui fait 200 dates dans le monde entier
on a la chance continue grâce à la
réunion et peut-être que l'important
aussi dire sexuelle 24 ou circassiens ça
c'est deux mondes la compagnie zoreil
français met dedans lie l'ensemble de
l'humanité dans la de boni vient de
turquie de france d'anglais et à part à
toute l'amérique donc montre aussi
comment la culture elle peut rassemble
un tas de monde et c'est pas un détail
déjà par les temps actuels de dire que
nous peut mélanger à nous toutes
ensemble pour fabriquer n'a fait
après nous continuer à ce même d'après
avec la musique classique avec la garde
républicaine d'un réunionnais dedans qui
joue de la contrebasse très beau
programme avec douze musiciens qui
jouent du violon contrebasse tout ça
mozart tchaïkovski britten el gahs uno
très belle musique classique
pour la petite histoire vers le public
était venu à 46 ans pour l'inauguration
tenait rebelles y revient à cette année
il va tendre 46 ans mais qui combattants
nous a failli arrivent les gagnants
ensuite nous n'aura fred espel ça c'est
en décembre et fred espel peut-être
demande connaît pas vraiment que ça
allait mais c'est une personne a écrit
les plus belles musiques de la région et
comme pas un petit case en paille et sue
plateau banner atteinte à compte
d'artistes la réunion comme stéphanie
thazar pour la nouvelle génération
nicole dambreville d'achat tortillard
mais aussi jacqueline farreyrol
jean-marc pounoussamy la marie armande
et henri claude moutou et après une
résidence de los griot que fils de
danièle sa demie pajot qui au bas damier
et là ça serait une restitution pour
discuter avec eux pour écouter un peu
leur nouvel univers et une exposition au
théâtre champ fleuri avec la cité
d'architecturé de paris sur comment
réenchanter le monde
interrogea nous un peu sûr que ça il
veut dire l'architecturé au zona n'aura
des actions de sensibilisation que nous
fait avec les collèges puisque l'on aura
un collège de saint gilles et un collège
de l'étang salé que nous ferons aussi
avec les enseignants pour des ateliers
que nous fait aussi avec mes parents
pour x y avec les grands cirques ascione
de lille pour continuer à dialoguer mais
c'est aussi les rencontres avec le
public voilà le plus important c'est
continue aussi de travailler avec le
public puisque public ce n'est pas qu'un
mot nous vient ce spectacle c'est aussi
un monde que l'on vit de rencontre les
artistes